hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the bullet Chess
Championship it is a game between a
former world champion Jose Eduardo
Martinez Alcantara as I say a former
world champion I meant former uh World
under 18 Champion uh he wanted
um in 2017 I believe uh and he's facing
Hikaru Nakamura you can see there's a
bit of a difference in raiding but
Hikaru is one of the highest rated
people on chess.com in bullet I think
the top rating ever reached was uh maybe
even 3500 by him or alirez I'm not
really sure but yeah it's a very
exciting game but first let's discuss
the the change of scenery the remodeling
that we are doing for a moment in the
previous video you've seen a new setup
and you guys said okay I like it some of
you said I didn't like it some of you
said okay I prefer the new one but I
would like the some elements of the old
one the reason why I decided even to do
it is because the previous setup I was
using was meant to be used on different
monitors when I said different monitors
I mean monitors that have a different
aspect ratio today the standard on
YouTube and pretty much every everywhere
where you have a horizontal or or
vertical input is 69 16x9 and I was
using 16 by 10 so it's a bit of a
different idea and at the resolution I
was using is different it's a 1920 by
1200 and I should be using 1920 by 1 180
uh one zero eight zero and the reason uh
why this is so important is because
YouTube app had an update I I thought it
was only for uh for iPhones but it's
also for Android on the new update
whenever you start a video in a
horizontal view it just gets zoomed in
the problem is because I was using 1610
instead of 69 there were two black
stripes on the edge of my videos and
well the YouTube app just did not want
that there so it zoomed in for the two
stripes to disappear it wanted the
entire screen to be filled with actual
video content and that meant that I lost
content on the bottom and on the top so
whenever you guys loaded it up you would
have to pinch zoom out in order to get
access to everything all the elements
that were available on the screen and
that's a pretty big issue you know you
want to just swipe and you want to watch
videos or you want to start a video
without having to zoom in I mean it's a
it's a an extra step that no uh living
being should be required to take so
that's why I was forced to do some
remodeling here and yes I know you
really like the previous uh setup it's
something that I did uh by myself I'm
not a very good graphic designer so I
created everything you know in really
retro Style with poor colors poor fonts
and you know poor element placement but
as you guys enjoyed it so much there
were in fact some comments where you
guys said okay maybe let's use the new
design for bullet and Blitz Games let's
use the old design for rapid and
classical games uh so uh probably it's
gonna be something like that and uh
we're doing some remodeling on the old
design we're gonna bring it back but
first we have to prepare it just you
know respect the aspect ratio of today's
standards and then I will uh then I will
return to it so uh until that is done we
will be using this one it might get
tweaked a little bit from video to video
but uh for the moment this is what we
will be using so that being said uh
let's check it out uh the game I mean
and if you guys have any other
suggestions that you would like
um us to incorporate in the in the
actual interface I will definitely
consider it uh also one one big
important question do do you guys really
want the clock times uh I'm I'm not
adding the engine bar that's something
I'm never adding to my videos because
I'm uh completely against that it ruins
the magic of actually uh enjoying a
chess game you know because you always
know who's better but if you if you guys
really really want the clock times I
could uh Implement that but it's just
not going to be possible to use that for
older games and I I constantly jump from
older games to newer games here okay we
have clock times it's uh it's a bullet
game and chess.com but if I'm showing a
game that Bobby Fierce played I don't
have the exact clock times from from
that error so I don't know do you guys
want that also maybe comment on that now
yeah okay A bit of a longer intro but I
thought it was relevant to address this
now let's check out the game uh Jose
Eduardo Martinez Alcantara has the white
pieces and he opens with Ponte E4 we
have Pawn to D6 Pawn to D4 and now Pawn
to A6 by hikar what is he even doing
here well it's um sort of a sort of a
pierce defense but a really really weird
one A6 was played only a handful of
times with Bishop to D3 now B5 and
already as of move three we have a
completely new game so okay Pawn to C3
we have Bishop to B7 and you you're
probably thinking okay now Hikaru will
go after d for Pawn but it's really hard
to do that as D6 has already been played
in similar setups when you play Bishop
B7 and Knight to F6 to go after the E4
Pawn you want to have the possibility of
going D5 so maybe E6 D5 instead so this
is very just very weird Knight's the D2
We have Knight to D7 and now Knight to G
to F3 we have Pawn to E5 now and castles
and Hikaru strikes at the center with
Pawn to C5 we have Rook D1 and Knight G2
F6 both players just continue in
development not trying to
and get rid of any tension in the center
Knight to F1 and now Bishop to E7 and
you know as they say in chest to take is
a mistake if there's no good reason to
take something don't don't capture it
Knight to G3 and now castles with Bishop
to G5 just you know developing pieces on
optimal squares Rook to E8 and queen to
D2 We have Pawn to H6 challenging the
bishop and the bishop goes back to E3 uh
Bishop to fate and we're gaining control
over the E file and now Pawn to D5 and
while Pawn to D5 it does give you access
to d square so you're controlling a lot
more space in your opponent's half of
the board it also gives up control over
the C5 Square so Hikaru immediately
utilizes that pawn to C4 clears up the
C5 Square for his Knight push it back to
C2 and now just Knight the C5 and yes
you could capture on C5 but you are then
giving up a bishop and you really like
your Bishop maybe later on you can use
it to attack the black king So H3 and
now King the H7 with King to H1 and now
Pawn to G6 uh we have Knight to H2 and
now Bishop to G7 and of course you want
to play F4 But first you prepare it Rook
to F1 uh so Queen to C7 Hikaru develops
the queen connects the Rooks and The
Rook 8 to E1 now we have Rook the E7
preparing to double up uh and finally
Pawn to F4 he captures an F4 Bishop
captures and now Rook 88 nicely doubling
up here going after the E4 pawn and
Hikaru says if you want that pawn you
can capture it but you have to calculate
a lot so he car plays Knight to G4 uh
can D4 Pawn be captured and Y is Hikaru
offering it well
uh it's uh it's impossible to calculate
this even with uh a lot of time on the
clock but in a bullet game and I think
in the first video that I've covered
from this Championship I said that it
was a one plus one bullet tournament no
it's not it's actually one plus zero
this is actual bullet and this is I mean
this is a real fight so the point is if
you start capturing here with Knight F
let's say characters on e4 then we have
Knight captures only for then Knight
captures then Bishop captures then Rook
captures on e4 Rook captures and E4 Rook
captures I need for uh there's even
Bishop captures on H6 as you are
controlling the H6 Square twice and now
you get F5 and what is happening here
who can calculate all of this from that
uh point of capture uh very very hard to
imagine uh let's say Bishop captures and
G7 even just Queen captures on G7 and
now uh how do you how do you play this
it's such a such a weird position you
can't really move the Knight if you move
the Knight then uh Queen is coming to E5
it's such a such a weird weird position
probably the queen to G5 will be played
then F captures and G4 then Queen to H4
with check and okay you're down the
bishop but you have excellent control of
the entire board let's take the Jade
Queen to d8 check and we might even see
a nice repetition here so completely
crazy position but instead uh Nakamura
said nope let's go Knight captures on G4
and bear in mind this is all played with
a one plus zero uh one minute plus zero
seconds increment time format H captures
on G4 and now Knight to D7
re-maneuvering the Knight we have Pawn
to G5 and now Pawn to H5 Hikaru should
have just captured here he played Pawn
to H5 but again there's no way to
calculate this yes Knight captures on H5
is a move we can all see that then you
open up this diagonal then you play E5
but the problem is uh okay let's say
knife captures on each one we have to
discuss it because it's beautiful if G
captures an H5 there's Bishop captures
on D6 where you can't capture because of
E5 check and you blunder a queen so
obviously you're not going to do that
you might play Queen d8 and now Pawn to
E5 again with check and after the king
will spawn to E6 now can you survive
this with black and maybe because it's
bullet but chances are you're not going
to do it the problem with this is and I
think this is the easier line to
calculate what if your car doesn't take
the Knight what if your car just plays
Rook to h8 and now he wants to claim the
H file for himself okay you've grabbed
the pawn you might even grab the bishop
but now this comes with checklet the
King G1 Knights the E5
uh who who's to say that white is better
here of course you're up a pawn but will
you be able to to play against black
with the black having the open H file
for his Rook very very hard to say uh so
that's why after Pawn to H5 we have
knighted the F5 instead of trying to
sacrifice a piece this way uh and Hikaru
accepts it g captures on F5 e captures
on F5 and now uh Hikaru plays Ponte F6
which is not the absolute best way to go
you have to trade or trade everything
off first uh I know we're showing a a
few lines more than I usually would for
a bullet game uh but it's such a
beautiful position that I thought I
absolutely should and I have checked out
all the games that they've played so
that that's why this is why I chose this
one and okay you get a you you get a
playable position but Hikaru played
Ponte F6 and now comes Pawn to G6 with
check Rook the E6 is the move you really
want to play here but the G6 check was
played King to G8 and now Rook the E6
but now Knight to E5 by Hikaru Queen to
D1 of course you want to capture here
and go Queen to H7 but still you have to
wonder what happens after King to f8 how
do you what's the follow-up there well
Queen to C5 by Hikaru and now Queen
captures an H5 and now uh Hikaru gets a
very very winning position here again
you you have to go for an all-out uh
capture Fest here Rook captures have
captures any uh uh uh sorry uh F
captures on E6 Queen captures on D5 now
and isolation 2 threatening Checkmate so
white has to trade Queens captures
captures and now Bishop captures on F6
Bishop captures and he says Bishop
captures King captures and you get the
same game with equal material Bishops of
uh the same color uh probably black a
little bit better as it's hard to say if
you will be able to keep the G6 pawn and
it's a double Pawn but yeah that's how
you should play it after Queen captures
an H5 like we said once Queen H7 lands
and King comes the Fate what's the
follow-up and Hikaru asks that same
question Queen captures on D5 now
threatens Checkmate on G2 we have Rook
Dev two defending and now Rook captures
an E6 F captures an E6
F captures on E6 and now Hikaru should
play just real captures but he played
Knight to D3 and now again it's white
who's better here incredible but that's
just how bullet just works Queen H7
check King to f8 and now Bishop captures
on D3 C captress on D3 and now you are
white here what do you play it's such a
tricky position uh feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best continuation for Jose Eduardo while
I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
connection and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures and D6 beautiful move and you
can't really ignore this yeah if you
play Rook D7 is just a very tricky Rook
captures an F6 check and now if Bishop
captures Queen to F7 Checkmate but even
if you don't capture if you go here just
Queen to G8 check Bishop to f8 and now
Rook captures or queen characters will
be Checkmate so that would be
devastating so Queen captures and D6 was
played by Hikaru and now comes Rook
captures on F6 with check and Hikaru of
course starts running away if you
capture then he gets checkmated on F7 so
King the E7 now comes Queen captures on
G7 with check King to d8 and now uh the
move you have to find is a queen
captures on B7 it looks like such a
boring move because I mean okay you just
grab a bishop but he decided against it
he probably thought that after captors
maybe D2 is a bit too strong but there's
E7 check and now how do you react to
this queen captures an E7 is met with
Queen the A8 with Chuck King to D7 and
now Queen to C6 check and after King
today it Rook to D6 trick finally
connects you have to give up your queen
and then after Queen captures you will
pick up the pawn as well so unlock the
calculate for bullet but you know that's
why that's why they are there playing it
as they are the best and best at it so
Rook to F7 was played instead but now it
is definitely Hikaru who is winning he
just plays Bishop to C6 and says Nope
you will not be playing Rook to D7 uh
with rooked for now trying to win
hikaru's Queen with Rook to D4 but
Hikaru just plays Pawn to D2 he says
this is not a problem as I am getting
another queen so Rook the D4 is played
we have D1 check and it was in this D1
Queen check and he was in this position
animal 41 that Jose Eduardo Martinez
Alcantara resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here here you
don't have a move as the queen is
covering the H2 Square you have to
capture the queen and after Queen
captures King to H2 and of course now
you're just up a rook up a bishop of
course completely winning so yeah
beautifully done here and you can see
just how incredible these players are uh
when uh they can play I mean okay like I
said when you have a bullet that's one
plus one one minute plus one second
increment for for Grand Masters there
are these this strong that one second
increment is so much for them that the
the games are so much higher level but
here with zero increments sometime
sometimes you will if there's a lot of
moves being played you will have to
pre-move you will have to do this you
will have to do that you know you will
have to claw your way out of the
position and here uh playing such a
complicated game at such a level I think
it's absolutely incredible and yeah if
you guys have any of the games that are
uh that were played yesterday as so many
of them have been played uh do use
hashtag suggestion and I will uh
definitely try to go over it while we
are still improving and tweaking the
interface uh but yeah for those of you
who are interested here are the
standings after uh yesterday's uh
clashes so Hikaru defeated Jose Martinez
with a score of 14-6 uh Daniel
naroditski was better than Andrew tang
with 14 and a half to six and a half
which is absolutely incredible for those
of you who have been following Andrew
Tang AKA The Penguin for quite some time
you know just how strong he is at these
uh fast time controls I mean he plays
Bullet he plays hyper bullet he plays
the ultra bullet I mean he he plays it
all uh Magnus defeated uh Tuan Min but
he did struggle with him and you know it
was uh a give and take
you couldn't really guess who would take
the match but at the end it was just
magnus's end game still that that
prevailed and alireza fury defeated
Alexander Alexander Bortnick with a
score of 11 to 5. so yeah we'll see what
happens next in the in the semi-finals
so stay tuned for that and yeah if you
have any game that you would like to see
from here or any game from any
tournament that is currently being
played or was ever played do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over that so
yeah sorry about uh talking a bit longer
in this video but I just wanted to clear
up what is happening why we are changing
exchanging the interface what we are
going uh you know towards what we want
to accomplish and hopefully that's what
we will be able to do but yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
John Austin notkin plays Paul Miller and
Brad rod for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day